they said we have a search warrant for
the place to stand up against the fence
and they first all of us hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV today I'm
talking with Kristen can t the director
and co-producer a Farmageddon a new
documentary about raids on raw milk
farms and farmers who make raw milk
products Kristen thanks for coming
thanks for having me your documentary is
opened in DC over the summer it's going
to be in New York and in California as
well congrats the Kech line is the
unseen war on American family farms what
is this war the war is on farmers and
coop owners the coop is formed by
neighbors that just want to get milk or
for meat and vegetables from their
neighboring farms and they've been shut
down by the government and they've been
shut down because I mean partly because
of raw milk in some cases in the movie
in some cases it's about the milk but in
other cases it's about the meat and then
another case it's a sheep farm so what
you know who was going after them and
what's the you know why did they go
after the sheep in every raid it's a
different story it's different
regulations that are in place that are
really hurting our small farms and coop
owners a whole flock of sheep were
killed because of the threat of mad cow
disease and sheep don't get mad cow
disease so who was doing the threatening
I'm in that case it was the USDA but
it's not always a USDA sometimes it's
the state agricultural departments or
state health departments and in other
cases it's the FDA is this type of
activity on the rise it is well right
now there is a document called healthy
family 2020 on you can find it on the
FDA website and written there it says
that the FDA would like to reduce the
number of states that allow the sales of
raw milk by 2020 what they're trying to
make all food safe
and they they come from the mindset that
bacteria to kill the bacteria to get rid
of all of the bacteria now when we do
this we know that there's lots of good
bacteria that we need our bodies need
raw milk is full of them meat that's not
irradiated you know fresh meat is full
of great back to good bacteria also when
these products are produced in crowded
areas and fed only grain and not allowed
outside and not allowed grass we get an
unhealthy product instead of focusing on
that problem the FDA and the USDA seem
to want to regulate all food but that's
the food that's produced in a safe
manner and in an unsafe manner now this
and this is a kind of strange time for
this to be happening right because I
mean we Americans have seen whether it's
at a corner market or a farmer's market
or in even stores like Kroger or Walmart
just an enormous proliferation of
organic produce of new types of meat of
grass-fed versus other types of grain
fed you know why are people trying to
limit our choice right at a moment when
new choices are becoming available and
desired by the public or buying public
it does seem that with the rise of
farmers markets that there's more and
more regulations that are that are
making it harder for the farmer to get
these products to market that the new
food safety bill for example is pages
and pages of vegetable regulations it
doesn't have anything to do with the
meat and the eggs that you know that are
produced in factory farms with
Farmageddon what what's your hope you
know if the movie is a success what will
it have done I guess remember one of the
regulator's see this and see that maybe
they're well-intentioned laws to keep us
safe are having unintended consequences
by really hurting our small farmers and
this is all I mean part of it is that
they'll say oh this is just about
information or making sure consumers
know what they're buying but I mean
people who tend to shop it through coops
or belong to coops or buy raw milk
they're always among the most informed
consumers out there most of them are
extremely well-informed I used to be a
complete germophobe I was afraid of
bacteria and I was sick in my son this
is how I found it my son was very sick
with allergies and asthma and so we I
had to re-educate myself that to embrace
bacteria and good bacteria was actually
good for you and your gut needs to be
aligned with it and he we all became
healthy you're not a filmmaker you're
not a professional filmmaker you've said
in other settings that this is the only
movie that you're going to make what are
you going to be doing after this movie
runs its course and after this I would
like to open up a farm-to-table
restaurant and I hope that the
regulations are eased by then to make
things like that easier have many chefs
have told me how how it's very hard to
to support the local farms because the
government is making it so hard for
these small farms to get their products
to the restaurants and to any market
well Kristen can t director and
co-producer of Farmageddon thank you for
talking to us and good luck with the
movie getting the message out thank you
for raising TV i'm nick gillespie